oh
[Musique]
deux parents de beaux enfants une maison
un souper en famille
la selle est en apparence banale mais
pour qui veut le mile-end nathan et
livia le quotidien est un véritable
casse tête
chaque semaine des fois même à chaque
journée on modifie notre ère on change
nos plaintes pour s'adapter pour que
tout convient depuis que tout le monde
soit à la bonne place au bon moment
mylène chabot sera bientôt infirmières
son conjoint travaille dans l'industrie
du bois
pour eux le 9 à 5 n'existe pas keaven
terriens et préposés à la petit camion
chez matériaux blanchet
je ne vais pas d'horaires fixes mais
c'est souvent 6h du matin c'est entre 5
et 20 heures 17 heures et 20 heures le
soir se joue en dix saisons
aujourd'hui après l'école nathan 10 ans
et livia 7,1 accompagnent leur père au
travail parce qu'ils n'ont pas le choix
c'est parfois aussi le col matin il n'a
pas de service de garde pour les
familles avec des horaires atypiques en
dessous d'un prêt ce qui des fois on a
encore envie de dormir sur caen peu pop
y en a mais le déjeuner ici j'aime chaud
mais juge qu on se lève tous les matins
et puis on n'est pas grand chose à faire
beaucoup de parents de saint pamphile
font face au problème la conciliation
travail famille
présentement les services de garde au
phare ici aux écoliers ne couvre que les
heures qui précèdent ou suivent
immédiatement les heures de classe
[Musique]
dans cette ville de 2400 habitants
adossée à la frontière du maine
tout le monde vit au rythme des camions
chargés de bois l'industrie rôle de jour
de soir et jusqu'au milieu de la nuit
dans les usines
saint-pamphile vie le plein emploi cette
situation crée aussi les défis avant
cela je vous dirais les cv sa rentrée le
10 12 cv par semaine c'est l'on fait des
mois on en import
la population vit des travailleurs
prennent leur retraite et les jeunes
quittent la ville pour faire leur vie
ailleurs
depuis la dernière année c'est quelque
chose qu'on n'avait jamais vécu ici à
saint pamphile manqué de gens comme
sophie demandeur puis un gros roulement
aussi dans la main d'oeuvre
ces profils doit donc attirer et retenir
de jeunes familles
pour y arriver la communauté s'est
mobilisée et lancera un service de garde
ouvert seulement le soir et la nuit
le presbytère va être aménagée au cours
des prochains mois pour recevoir des
enfants de 0 12 ans dès le printemps
prochain
la garderie accueillera une trentaine de
jeunes noctambules
donc si ça va vraiment être aménagée
comme un salon dans une maison familiale
régulière on aura des champs man et
nager comme à la maison
on aura un lit qui appartient à jonathan
et que jonathan retrouvera de soir en
soir centraux sont au lit à lui ce
projet est unique au québec on est donc
allé chercher l'inspiration ailleurs
notamment à angers en france
une crèche qui accueille les enfants des
travailleurs de soir et de nuit 24
heures sur 24
c'est évident que ça va faire là envie
de beaucoup d'autres villages villes au
québec qui vivent ces réalités lors le
projet pilote de saint pamphile durera
trois ans ce qui est très exceptionnel
aussi c'est que c'est un partenariat
entre le privé et le public
la société de développement industriel
local là se disent pas acheter le
presbytère et perrin les aménagements
des entreprises comme my back et
matériaux blanchette la caisse populaire
la municipalité et la mrc finançons les
dépenses courantes
une subvention du ministère de la
famille couvrira les salaires les
parents eux devront payer entre 20 et 35
$ par jour pour le service reste à les
convaincre de laisser leurs enfants dans
une garderie le soir ou la nuit par une
belle possibilité puis on serait
beaucoup plus proches pourraient dormir
un peu plus longtemps que qu'est-ce
qu'on fait présentement à défaut les
maisons d'hôtes au dos sont un peu
chamboulé par nos oreilles offrir moins
pressés en jour est plus pis on a répète
plus le temps de faire des heures farc
avec cette nouvelle garderie de nuit
saint pamphile espère attirer et retenir
des familles son avenir en dépend
[Musique]